thierry coville bonjour merci de
répondre sur rt france tôt ce matin en
direct une bataille judiciaire donc
devant la cour internationale de justice
entamée il ya deux ans est ce qu'elle
peut effectivement cette chemise sur les
sanctions américaines ont posé en terran
en gros qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
mais ses audiences à l'est aujourd'hui
je pense que concrètement les dirigeants
iraniens ne pense pas que il va y avoir
un jugement qui qu'il commandait
annulerait les sanctions américaines ou
alors voir ja happ les relations des
états unis avec la cour internationale
de justice voit mal les états unis
remettre en cause leur sanction en cause
d'un jugement que je pense surtout cela
traduit s'est teint les efforts de
l'iran pour montrer qu'ils sont du côté
du droit international et contre les
états unis il faut bien noter que
quelque part l'effet de leur donne
raison
tous les jugements récemment tout ce qui
s'est passé montre bien que la
communauté internationale reconnaît qu'
il ya un pays qui est du côté droit
international c'est l'iran est un pays
qui ne respectent pas ces états unis sur
ce sont les faits donc c'est plus une
politique iranienne en fait c'est un
bras de fer de longue haleine mais même
s'il en ressort que la cour de justice
internationale est apte à traiter cette
affaire
de quels véritables moyens
dispose-t-elle et surtout de quelle
marge de manoeuvre aurait alors liront
pour valeur disposer niro pour pouvoir
négocier si vous voulez on sait depuis
le début mais il faut bien que les faits
sont importants donc les états unis
sortent de l'accord en mai 2018 et
réimposé sanctions contre veut dire à
quasiment toute la communauté
internationale
et on voit bien que leur politique
vis-à-vis de l'iran ça devient presque
je dirais une commande dire une
caricature ils sont les seuls à dire
j'ai envie de ça je veux ça et toute la
communauté internationale leur donne
tort rappelons-nous comme ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières semaines dans
l'accord de juillet 2015 était prévu une
fin dans l'embargo sur les armes contre
l'iran en octobre 2020 les etats-unis
ont dit non où seuls comptent maintenant
il n'en est pas question que c'est un
corpus et en vain auprès de faim et ils
ont voulu même imposé mettre en place
qu'une résolution soit votée au conseil
de sécurité des nations-unies je vous
rappelle qu'il
même pas arrivé à ce que cette
résolution aille jusqu'au conseil que
des nations unies ensuite ils ont voulu
mettre en place de mécanismes de snap
bac c'est à dire réinstaurer toutes les
sanctions contre l'iran ce qui était
prévu dans l'accord 2015 si l'iran ne
respectait pas d'une certaine façon
d'accord l'ensemble des membres qui sont
toujours membres de cet accord ont dit
aux états unis vous ne pouvez pas à la
fois sortir de l'accord en mai 2018 et
je répète vous m contre la communauté à
travers les ré reposer des sanctions
extraterritoriale et d'un autre côté
quand ça vous arrange dire on est
toujours parti de ce fait toujours par
cet accord et on remet en place et
sanctions donc je pense qu on est ce que
ce qu'essaye de faire l'iran c'est de
montrer qu'ils sont du côté du droit
international c'est plus on va dire le
politique d' influence mettre en place
des points alors vous allez dire
concrètement ça change pas grand chose à
la situation économique en iran les
sanctions américaines et écrase
l'économie iranienne
mais c'est important pour les dirigeants
iraniens récemment le président iranien
a dit suite à ces jugements
ces événements constituaient des nations
unies a dit on gagne sur le plan du
droit international
c'est sûr que ça suffit pas aux à la
population iranienne qui est en train de
beaucoup souffrir des sanctions en me
disant c'est la stratégie gerrans en
attendant les prochaines élections mais
rythme justement la prochaine élection
présidentielle aux états unis a lieu
donc le 3 novembre mais on al'impression
qu'avec la pandémie de coronavirus les
enjeux diplomatiques entre washington et
téhéran passe un peu au second plan
quelle issue possible selon vous entre
les deux pays à terme justement on pense
à cette élection de novembre prochain
est ce que ça peut changer des choses
oui très clairement je pense que là on
ne peut pas dire quand j'ai eu quand je
lis parfois que ça va rien changer et
étaient assez faux sur plans d'effets de
nouveaux jobs hayden a dit qu'ils
reviennent qui reviendrait dans l'accord
alors qu'on sait que trump espère que
les iraniens vont tout d'un coup
négocier avec lui je pense qu'il serait
mon avis qu'ils seraient très incertain
même s'il est réélu donc si joe biden
est élu il revient dans l'accord donc ça
veut dire que les sanctions américaines
réimposées suite à la sortie des états
unis de l'accord en mai 2018 sont
annulées et donc l'iran par exemple
pourra explorer tout son pétrole donc ça
changerait énormément de choses pour
l'économie iranienne et je crois
beaucoup d'entreprises étrangères
est entreprise européenne et française
en particulier regardent avec intérêt
cette élection parce que ça voudrait
dire une réouverture du marché règne
d'un autre côté et là je vous suis
ça veut pas dire que tous les problèmes
entre l'iran et les etats-unis auront
disparu mais on va dire on rentrerait
dans une politique un petit peu plus
normale du côté américain avec sans
doute ils reviendraient dans l'accord
est sans doute on peut penser des
négociations semble difficile
s'ouvrirait sur d'autres champs comme la
politique iranienne dans la région le
projet balistique iranien donc les
tensions subsisterait mais au moins il y
aurait il y aurait plus de normalité on
va dire d'une politique iranienne des
états unis plus classique avec une
diminution des tensions
merci tirer comme elle d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'iran